uh my name is karina curto i'm a math
professor at penn state and i want to
talk to you today about
uh a certain model that i think provides
a unifying framework for many
neuroscience phenomena
so let's get started uh so the question
to motivate our work is
are questions about sequences and more
generally attractors and neural networks
and specifically we are concerned with
dynamic attractors not just static
attractors and these are the ones that
maybe you know these are the ones that
can provide a mechanism for generating
sequences of activity
central pattern generators
other kinds of rhythms and oscillations
and so this is really
the focus and
we
we want to understand how
these dynamic attractors and how
sequences emerge from
the detailed pattern of connectivity of
a network as reflected in the
connectivity graph so this is trying to
make a connection to the kinds of data
that come out of connectome research
all right
so the model that
the mathematical model
that we use as a setting for for most of
our work is threshold linear networks
and these are very simple firing rate
models of neural dynamics where every
neuron is
has a firing rate that's represented by
one of these variables x sub i
and the dynamics given here on the right
have a leaked term negative x sub i
and a threshold non-linearity so the
argument inside the brackets if it is
positive so meaning if the recurrent
inputs
to the neurons plus some
threshold plus external input value b
sub i if that exceeds zero then
you have an identity function so if you
look down to the right
there is a
red threshold linear function that is
the one that the the brackets plus is
reflecting
so you will get identity function if
that's positive if the argument is
positive and you will get a zero if it's
negative
and
we will refer to
these dynamics in terms of the w matrix
but
we will also
pay attention to a more specific model
that i'll introduce in a second
so
these thresholds in your networks
remarkably can generate all kinds of
nonlinear dynamics including
multi-stability so like multiple stable
six points or multiple attractors limit
cycles chaos and even quasi-periodic
attractors moreover all these different
kinds of dynamics arise for effectively
inhibitory w and for a constant external
input
so these networks have been studied a
long time in neuroscience and they've
been used to model a really wide variety
of dynamic behavior
but i think mathematically the
the real
push that inspired a lot of the work
that we do
came from holland or hong kong
and others um
nearly 20 years ago now they wrote a
couple of papers that
uh
really kicked off kind of a more serious
mathematical study of these networks and
then i followed up with on the digital
and vladimir
and then katie morrison and so you can
think of these as analogous to the
hopfield model in the sense that
they have they can encode multiple
attractors and in the symmetric case
hollis or sung and others were able to
prove a a result that was very much like
the hopfield model guaranteeing
convergence of the attractors
convergence to a stable fixed point in
the symmetric case
all right but
we care more about the non-symmetric
case and in particular we care about
stable and unstable fixed points and
here are some references for the papers
that i
uh will talk about
okay so the motivating question is again
what is the relationship between the
attractors of a network and its
underlying architecture
and before i keep going i just want to
take a moment to acknowledge my
collaborators on this so especially
katie morrison at the top left
she has been really my
co-author on
basically all this work for the last
five or six years
she's my co-pi on the brain grant and
is really
equal sort of equal pi to me and
everything
uh caitlyn and juliana and
the other kaitlyn and josh are all
uh current and former graduate students
chris and jessie former postdocs
and vladimir onda other mathematicians
that i've worked with on early
parts of this work and then
there are some more names here other
people who
have joined in
okay
so let me
get going back to the threshold of the
new networks we really can think of them
as this patchwork of linear systems so
one thing that's really nice about this
model of neural network is that we can
piggyback off of the considerable
knowledge that we have about linear
systems of odes and kind of
patch that together into a into a
nonlinear
framework
and
one of the sort of first things that you
will notice about these networks when
you study them is that there's actually
a one-to-one correspondence between the
fixed points of the network and the
allowed support so in other words the
fixed points can be labeled by
the linear chamber in which they arrive
so if you think about these equations
they break up they partition your state
space into a bunch of different chambers
um
because the argument inside the
non-linearity defines hyperplanes it
defines a hyperplane arrangement for you
and so you really end up chopping up the
state space into these different chamber
linear chambers where you have an
honest-to-goodness linear system of
differential equations that's governed
in the dynamics and in each of those
linear chambers there may or may not be
a fixed point
and and so the game of figuring out what
the fixed points of these networks is
really is the same as figuring out what
chambers contain the fixed point
associated to their linear system
okay and so you can um
with this patchwork of linear systems
idea here's a
an example of different chambers for a
network with just three neurons
and you can see here a trajectory
starting at an unstable starting near an
unstable fixed point and spiraling out
into a nice limit cycle of behavior um
traversing this trajectory actually
traverses four different chambers
okay
so you know a lot of the research that
we've been doing for the brain
initiative has been focused on a special
case of threshold linear networks which
are combinatorial threshold linear
networks and this is a special case
that's really designed to tackle the
question of connectivity specifically so
in these networks you have you can start
from a graph just any directed graph
and there is a recipe for how to assign
weights
to the edges
of the network based on this graph so
when there is an edge between two nodes
we assign this weight negative i plus
epsilon so you can see here the w i j
formula down below
shows that you have a negative one plus
epsilon if j goes to i in the graph
and if there's no edge from j to i then
you have this weight negative one minus
delta and what these two values are
would represent are a weaker and a
stronger inhibition so epsilon and delta
are positive quantities and so basically
what you have is an inhibitory network
where you have two kinds of inhibition
you have strong inhibition and weak
inhibition and
in that pattern of strong and weak
inhibition is really what's governing uh
the dynamics it's really going to shape
the attractors
so we can think of this as a generalized
winner take all network with this
pattern of strong and weak inhibition
and for fixed parameters so fixed choice
of epsilon delta and theta which is an
external input to the network
the differences in dynamics are purely
due
to differences in the graph structure so
this really is a way to isolate the role
of connectivity in generating
in these internally generated dynamics
okay so just to give you some examples
of dynamics that are generated by these
networks
here's one where you have a very simple
cyclically symmetric graph on five nodes
and it produces a limit cycle attractor
that cycles through one two three four
five you can look the colors in the
attractor uh in the rate curves are
matching of course the colors in the in
the nodes of the graph or the neurons
and you can see that you cycle through
this nice limit cycle attractor however
the very same graph produces another
attractor
which has very different looking almost
melty rate curves and uh we call this
one the gaudi attractor because it
reminds me of the architect and
barcelona
so these networks for for different
graphs can actually have exhibit
coexistence of many different kinds of
attractors so
here's an example of you know just draw
a graph on nine neurons and
choose an epsilon and delta and we see
here that we actually get four different
attractors that coexist in this network
so you go from one you the
activity chooses one or the other based
purely on initial conditions so
for some initial conditions you fall
into this limit cycle the black on the
top right the black curve by the way is
total population activity you can see
that it is remarkably stable even as the
individual neurons
oscillate quite a bit
you can have a chaotic attractor below
that
which has even more stable total
population activity but lots of
switching back and forth on on the
active neurons
and there are also two stable six point
attractors
and so again these all coexist in the
same network the only difference
that leads you to one solution over
another is initial conditions
okay so um i'm going to spend the rest
of the talk
basically going through applications of
two theorems that we were able to prove
so again we are mathematicians and so
we've been studying these networks and
trying to connect structural properties
of the graphs with dynamic properties of
the associated networks
so
this first theorem is about uh
subgraphs of uniform in degree so that
means that every node has the same
number of incoming and outgoing edges in
the graph
and the theorem that we have
although the slide didn't transcribe
well
something went off
going to the pdf apologize for that um
in the system but the theorem basically
says that if you have one of these as an
induced subgraph of a larger network
then uh
that subgraph supports a fixed point if
and only if no node outside of it
receives d plus one or more edges
from the nodes in the subgraph so let me
illustrate that um with an example so
the corollary is that if g is a cycle
your fixed point
corresponding to it survives if and only
if no node outside g receives two or
more edges from g so
what does that really mean so here's an
example graph on the left where you have
five nodes and you have a couple of
three cycles embedded in the graph so
two three five is a three cycle and one
four five is a three cycle okay on their
own
right isolated each of those would
produce a limit cycle where the neurons
oscillate in that order 145 or 235
however embedded in this graph what you
see is a difference
in the embedding of the following form
so the 145 cycle actually has a node 2
outside of it that's receiving two edges
from nodes in the cycle and therefore
has no
associated fixed point and no associated
attractor in contrast the 235 cycle
has
no such external node receiving two or
more edges from it and so you see you
have a very nice limit cycle
corresponding to that
okay so what we have just to
summarize is a theorem that tells us
when um certain subgraphs will have
surviving unstable six points in this
case and uh when those unstable fixed
points survive
we uh we predict that there will be a
corresponding attractor okay so in that
sense the the mathematical
theorem tells us when we will have
certain kinds of attractors
okay
and we have a similar result similar
corollary so the theorem was more
general these are corollaries for
special cases
similarly we can predict stable fixed
points uh from surviving clicks
okay so how can we use this
in uh in modeling so one very nice model
that we can make using the ideas of this
theorem is a simple counter so if you
take a bunch of two clicks like we have
here at the top and connect them in this
way and you have
arrows going forward from one to click
to the next
it turns out that all of these two
clicks will have surviving uh stable six
points and so this
tlm network has um you know six stable
fixed points one per two click
however if you give a pulse to the so if
you you know initi depending on initial
conditions you'll go to one fixed point
or another but if you start for instance
at the blue the light blue dark blue
fixed point and you give a pulse to the
whole network
so you can see um down below we have
these this pulse train
uh this global pulse to the whole
network will actually
kick the activity over into the next
stable fixed point so go from
say blue to green
and then from green to
pink and red and so on
and so this uh
based on the on the theoretical results
we're able to define to design an
extremely simple
counter network that will keep track of
how many pulses have come in based on
the the attractor that the network is in
where every pulse bumps you over
okay and keep in mind these are global
pulses they are not targeting specific
fixed points it's just like it's moving
it over every time
and we can have similarly a signed
counter where
you can have left and right pulses the
left pulses would stimulate the bottom
row of neurons the right pulses would
stimulate the top row of neurons and
similarly you can have then the activity
moving
left or right in this network
depending on pulses coming from the left
or the right and so for instance when
you have these experiments where an
animal is
running down a corridor and
counting cues on the left versus on the
right right this is a simple network
that would keep track of
um the net sign
that the the net number of you know left
minus right cues
okay and then we have another this is
kind of a fun tln roulette which is
if you get rid of some of the edges you
can get the activity to spin around and
kind of stop on a random
two click
okay so let me give you another example
if you think about place cell coding in
the hippocampus uh one thing that's very
interesting is when you zoom in and look
within
a cycle of the of the theta oscillation
you actually see neurons firing in
sequence not at stable fixed points so
this again suggests that maybe
periodic or dynamic attractors can be a
good model for position in this context
and so
again using that same theorem we talked
about before but now applying it to this
more complicated graph we have a nice
rule graphically knowing when the fixed
point will survive and then predicting
when the attractor will survive
and so we can come up with um
what i call a continuous in quotes
attractor network because it's not
really a continuum of attractors but it
is um a sort of a discrete family of
many attractors that are all of the same
type so there's this modularity to the
to the structure of the network
and what you see with the network like
this is from the mathematical theory we
can predict that we will have uh limit
cycles for each of these
pentagonal
sub networks
and stimulation can can move you from
from one to another
and moreover you can have a situation
where a global stimulation uh where
you're hitting sort of all of these red
nodes
you know one per attractor so the the
stimulus doesn't you know know where the
position is doesn't know where you are
it's just hitting the whole network um
at once and it's always the same
so these identical theta pulses that are
hitting you know this distributed set of
red nodes will again like in the counter
case move you from one attractor to the
next this is another mechanism by which
you can have
position tracking
um in a in a sort of more complex
network where internally the attractors
are not fixed points this time that they
are
sequential right so they are dynamic
attractors and the neurons are firing in
sequence
and you can even add some noise
to
the matrix and you can see that the
noise
can cause some failures of transitions
but overall it's quite robust and so
again you have kind of these global
theta pulses
that can move you
from one attractor to the next even
though the external post knows nothing
about the current
position of the of the network activity
within the family of attractors
okay and uh
finally maybe i'll just take a few more
minutes to talk about
one more theorem
which is about cyclic unions so it turns
out
there are many theorems that we have
where we can predict
the fixed points of a network that is
generated by gluing together
smaller networks okay and so in this
case the structure is a cyclic union so
you have smaller networks taiwan tau two
etc i'm not showing the connections
within those but then they're glued
together in the cyclic fashion having
all the edges going forward from one
component to the next but none of the
back edges
and in this setup we have this nice
theorem
that tells us that the fixed points of
the larger network
are basically unions of fixed points of
fixed point supports of the component
networks so in other words if you know
the fixed points for the individual
components you can work out the fixed
points for the whole network in a very
simple way
and
this is an example of actually doing
that so
it's a little complicated slide but
this is really showing that from working
out the fixed points of these individual
small networks and the blobs
we can figure out all the fixed points
for the entire network in two examples
okay so i'll end with an application of
this and
and that is to central pattern generator
circuits and in this case uh my student
juliana worked out a central pattern
generator circuit for quadruped gates
so these are the familiar you know like
for a horse walk trot you know gallop
bound pace um i'm not sure the horse
does pronk but these are all familiar
quadruped gates
so these are locomotive patterns of
motion
and
uh
what we
found or what leanna found was that she
could genera she could create using
cyclic unions
networks that that um
generated activity for each of these
gates so here's a network that does
bound so the the neurons representing
the
um
the legs of the horse or or the animal
are
two three one two three and four so left
front right front left back and right
back
um those are the four
the four legs for the quadruped motion
and um this is a cyclic union
architecture which is
and using this she was able to create
the bound gates
um
using uh
another cyclic union that still involved
those same four nodes but some other
different auxiliary nodes she was able
to
create pace
and so you can see down at the bottom
right the pattern of activity of when
those legs hit the ground right and so
you can see um
these different patterns they actually
if you if you trace back
to what the different gates are they
match up with what you would expect for
these gates so this is one for trot
uh this is one for walk
okay and and finally for prank and so
the point was that she was able to find
to design using cyclic unions individual
networks that individually created all
of these gates but of course there are
these same four neurons involved one two
three and four for the different legs
okay so the question then was can we put
these together in a single network where
all five of these gates would coexist
okay and be accessible via different
initial conditions without having to
change any other parameters
and uh what juliana found was that yes
you could actually do this
so she was able to sort of really just
glue together take sort of the union of
all the edges from each of these
different
networks that she constructed for the
gates and
it's a simple you know this is not
fine-tuned at all these are standard
choices of epsilon and delta
these are the two parameters for making
the w matrix from the graph if you
remember there is a recipe for going
from the graph to the cellular matrix
and down here at the bottom left is the
adjacency matrix for kind of this giant
graph but it's really
if you think about it a very simple
graph that's just obtained by gluing
together
the the graphs for the individual gates
and so it has 24 neurons
and you know here's the matrix for it
and remarkably
this graph with all of these individual
limits
all of these individual cyclic unions
glued together
actually produces all five of the gates
okay and it's not hard to find initial
conditions for each gate because you
really just need to stimulate one of the
neurons
that is sort of unique to that gate so
there are overlapping neurons for the
five gates but then there are neurons
that only appear in one gate so if you
stimulate one of those neurons
you actually end up
in
in the appropriate gate and just want to
emphasize one more time the only
difference here is initial conditions
so in fact this means that you could
transition from one gate to another by
kicking the network
which effectively
you know resets the initial condition to
a different part of the state space so
here is an example
where i started in the bound gate so
there's some pattern of activity
of the of the feet hitting the ground
the legs hitting the ground for the
bound gate and then a little kick so
this is one neuron neuron 15
which is one of the unique neurons to
pace got stimulated here and that kicked
the activity from bound into pace you
can see there's a different pattern of
activity
in the in the pink rectangle here this
is the focus on the four neurons that
are actually determining the gate the
four neurons for the legs
and then another stimulation neuron 19
which is unique to walk kicks you into
the walk gate
and then neuron 23 kicks you into prank
neuron 17 kicks you into trot and so
here we see that not only do these gates
coexist in the same network but it's
very easy to transition between them
just by stimulating single neurons that
that will activate the different gates
and so this gives you a very clean
mechanism by which a central pattern
generator circuit a single central
pattern generator circuit can can encode
multiple gates and this is a
we're very excited to see this because
um
in the
in the literature
on these
types of models usually
uh one has to change parameters to go
from one gate to another
and so this having the attractors truly
coexist without any parameter changes
you know exact same connectivity matrix
as we think new is a new um discovery
that this can be done
and then we've added also noise to the w
matrix to see that there's some
robustness here um in the architecture
one percent noise and the w matrix
didn't um alter the dynamics at all
five percent noise and we did see a
transition failure
from
between some of the gates
in this last this last transition
so it does break down at some point
and i think i want to end there um so
i'll just
show my collaborators again and
thank you very much for attending my
virtual talk